[Music]
you've probably heard a lot about
covid19 this year
and more recently you might have heard
about viral testing
what are the different types of tests
available what happens to your samples
after a healthcare professional
retrieves them from your body
and how can scientists use these samples
to tell
whether or not you've been infected by
sars cov2
to answer these questions let's take a
look at two categories of viral tests
direct and indirect direct viral tests
detect
physical parts of the virus itself such
as viral rna
or viral antigens a positive result from
a direct test
usually indicates an active covid19
infection
the most widely used direct test to
diagnose covid19
is nucleic acid amplification using a
reverse transcriptase
polymerase chain reaction or rtpcr
in rtpcr sars cov2rna
is extracted from the samples and
amplified to detectable levels
to do this a sample is taken from the
oropharynx
or nasopharynx then in the lab
reverse transcriptase enzymes take the
viruses
single-stranded rna and use it as a
template
to create double-stranded dna
next this dna is copied over and over
using pcr
until millions or billions of the
replicates have been produced
and can be detected this process is
complex
and requires specialized testing
equipment but automation allows for rt
pcr testing to show results within
hours however factors such as
sampling backlog limited availability of
testing kits or lab reagents
or long distances between the testing
site and the laboratory
can mean you don't actually get results
for several days
antigen tests are another type of direct
test currently used to detect
active covid19 infections antigens are
molecules on the surface of the virus
that trigger the immune system to
produce antibodies
which are unique proteins that attack
only the antigens of a specific
virus in an antigen test for covid19
a sample is taken typically from the
nasopharynx
and tank antibodies to the sars cov2
virus are mixed with the sample
if the tagged antibodies attach to the
antigens in the sample
this indicates the virus is present in
the sample
rapid covid19 antigen tests are
relatively inexpensive
can be performed on site rather than
shipping samples to a lab
and can return results in less than an
hour
however they are not as accurate as
nucleic acid amplification tests
on the other hand indirect tests detect
the body's immune response to a viral
infection
serologic tests for covid19 also called
antibody tests or immunoassays are a
type of
indirect viral test that searches a
blood sample for the antibodies to sars
cov2
if these antibodies are detected this
indicates a viral infection occurred at
some point in the past
and may or may not still be active
this is because antibodies are typically
produced one to two weeks
after the onset of infection and remain
in your body
after the active infection has ended
there are a number of antibody detection
tests currently being used for covid19
such as enzyme-linked immunosorbent
assays
and chemoluminescent immunoassays
in these tests certain colored
substrates
or luminescent molecules indicate the
presence of the antibody in question
scientists are still determining what
level of protection from
future infections sars cov2 antibodies
may provide
if someone tests positive for covid19
viral antibodies
they may be able to donate their blood
to those currently battling the disease
or to laboratories developing treatments
does a positive direct test result
definitely mean that you've been
infected with the virus and vice versa
not always important concepts to
understand related to viral tests
are sensitivity and specificity
sensitivity is the ability of a test to
correctly identify people who
are infected and specificity is the
ability of a test to correctly identify
people
who aren't infected in other words
tests that are highly sensitive have a
high true positive rate
and a low false negative rate while
tests that are highly specific
have a low false positive rate and a
high true negative rate
nucleic acid amplification tests for
example
are highly specific because they detect
the precise
viral genetic sequence but the
sensitivity of nucleic acid
amplification tests for covid19
can vary depending on the amplification
protocol
used as well as when and from where the
sample is collected
thanks to viral tests scientists and
health care professionals are able to
diagnose patients
so they can receive proper treatment and
can monitor the evolution of public
health crises
such as the covid19 pandemic with a
combination of increasingly accurate and
accessible viral tests
continued adherence to public health
measures emergence of medications to
treat infections
and development of vaccinations to
prevent infections
the current pandemic will eventually
come to an end
[Music]
you